[Music]  Chloe's still with her man Tristan  despite his cheating scandal the new  moms celebrate the truths one-month  birthday baby troop is a month old  today of course Drew's birthday also  marks a month since news of Tristan's  infidelity broke the NBA star just gave  his first interview two uninterrupted  road-tripping podcast you down with kids  Namah cute one I got a couple a  Kardashian source exclusively tells et  Chloe want that too so could they both  celebrate her first Mother's Day  together a source says Chloe has no  plans to leave Tristan the video proof  of him with other women work her hard  but he begged for another chance is  there any part of you that roots for  Chloe and Tristan on tomorrow's live but  Kelly and Ryan's sister Kim speaks out  I'm always rooting for her yeah always  really as your Jimmy that's a great  answer yes  [Music]